[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800
83567 47 once again that's 800 835
6747 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Doug Bachelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact in 1846 San Francisco was a
small sleepy settlement with about 200
residents
but then the discovery of gold in the
northern California Hills in 1848
triggered one of the greatest migrations
in history by
1852 San Francisco became a booming city
of about
36,000 filled with makeshift tent houses
hotels stores saloons gambling halls and
yes even some
Churches by 1875 approximately one
quarter of California's entire
population resided in the city proper
sadly only about one out of five people
that embarked on the Gold Rush died
within 2 years and less than one in a
100 found enough gold to make the
grueling trip
worthwhile the Bible says there is
actually a city paved with gold that is
definitely worth the pilgrimage what do
you think Pastor Ross you know it's
interesting whenever you go to uh do a
little research on the gold rush there's
so many stories people went through so
much trials to get you they brought
their families they came with the wagon
loads and uh faced attacks by the
American Indians they ran in Terrible
Weather crossing the mountains and yet
just that dry for gold just uh kept them
going it is sad as you mentioned that
the vast majority of the people didn't
um strike Bonanza really the ones who
made a lot of money were the ones who
supplied the miners Merchants with tents
and gear yeah so there were some that
that scored everyone's looking for the
gold yeah yeah absolutely you know I
heard one little Side Story connected
with the gold rush that the ships that
were coming in bringing the U the 49ers
that that would either come from
Australia or go around South America and
they were coming up all the sailors jump
ship and the captains could not get
Crews to sail away and you can see some
of the very old pictures of the San
Francisco Bay filled with abandoned
sailing ships because they just couldn't
get people to sail away they all wanted
to come in and uh so it's just a
remarkable time in history but you know
the Bible tells us that um there is gold
that we should be driving for it's of
course a gold of God's love Jesus said
buy of me gold refined in the fire but
uh you read in Hebrews 11:8 by faith
Abraham obeyed when he was called to go
out to the place which he would receive
as an inheritance and he went out not
knowing where he was going by faith he
dwelt in the land of promise as in a
foreign country dwelling in tents with
Isaac and Jacob The Heirs with him of
the same promise for he waited for the
city that has foundations whose Builder
and maker is God and then it describes
that City Pastor Ross in Revelation 21:
18 the construction of its walls was of
Jasper and the city was pure gold like
glass and the foundations of the wall of
the city were adorned in all kinds of
precious stones and then it describes
these different Stones you go to verse
21 the 12 gates were 12 pearls each
individual gate was one Pearl and the
street of the city was pure gold like
transparent glass and so there is a city
of gold that's worth us making a
pilgrimage to and you know we do have a
study guide actually a book an amazing
facts book that talks about this very
real City uh this New Jerusalem it's
called heaven is it for real and this is
free we'll send it to anyone who calls
and asks the number to receive the gift
is 800 835
6747 and you just ask for offer number
189 or ask for it by name Heaven is it
for real we'll be happy to send that to
you if you're in North America if you're
outside of the US and you'd like to read
the book just go to the Amazing Facts
website just amazingfacts.org click on
the Free Library you'll be able to read
it there but if you'd like to get a hard
copy call and ask we'll be happy to send
it to you also there's one other way
that you can be uh receive this is
through text if you'd like to get a
digital copy of uh the gift you just
need to text the number pound 250 say
Bible answers live and then just ask for
it by name and we'll be happy to send it
to anyone who calls and asks all right
well before we go to the first call
let's start with a word of prayer dear
father we thank you once again that
we're all here able to study your word
and we ask your blessing upon this
program be with those who are listening
wherever they might be and as we always
ask Lord we know the Bible is your book
and so we ask the holy spirit to guide
us so that we can come to a clearer and
a full understanding of your will for
our lives and we ask this in Jesus name
amen amen first caller this evening
we've got Britany listening in
California Britney welcome to Bible
answers live yeah my question is how is
a Christian supposed to deal with
certain political regulations that are
completely against the Bible presented
by the
government okay good question well it's
not the first time in history that's
happened uh you can look in the Bible of
course when the government told the
mothers in Egypt to kill their baby boys
well jocked said I can't do that and she
put Moses in a basket and then the
government uh you know they told Daniel
that he should not pray to anyone but
the king and he had to stand up for his
faith or I should say kneel down for his
faith and then in uh Daniel 3 you got s
something similar king of babylon's
telling them the government laws had
bowed on and worship and the disciples
many of them died because they would not
follow the the laws of Rome that said to
worship Caesar now we should always obey
the laws of the land as long as they're
not in direct conflict with the laws of
God and so as far as possible Christians
should be the very best citizens but if
there's ever a political law or
principle that violates a Biblical
principle we always stand uh you know
with God in his word
first so hope that helps a little but
great question all right next caller
that we have is James listening in
Tennessee James you're on Bible an's
life thank you Pastor awesome thank you
Pastor Doug y'all have helped me so much
with the Three Angels message and it's
just been a blessing but yeah my
question today is um second
Thessalonians chapter 2 verse 4 MH and
starting with verse 10 it says and with
all them who deceive and for
unrighteousness in them they perish and
for this cause God will send them a
strong delusion so they will believe a
lie and it's saying God for this cause
will send them a strong delusion so
they'll believe a lie who is God
referring to And if every good gift
comes from God and everything is good
good good why would he send his people a
strong delusion so they will believe a
lie yeah that's that's a great question
and when you read this verse uh just on
the surface it sounds like why you know
everything is true God is truth why
would God send a lie it's similar to
that place in the Bible where um the
prophet is describing a dream and he
said and God said I will be a lying
spirit in the mouth of His prophets
that's Mah talking to Ahab and
Jehoshaphat and basically what it's
saying there is when they reject truth
Ahab rejected the truth then light when
rejected darkness comes in and if you
read the rest of this verse here going
back to 2 Thessalonians it says that for
this reason God will send them strong
delusion that they should believe a lie
that they might have be condemned who
did not believe the truth so what's left
if you reject truth the only thing you
got left is a lie and so it's basically
saying they've rejected the light and so
God is allowing them to believe a lie
God doesn't want anyone to be lost and
there's a verse I think in Hosea chapter
4 Pastor Ross verse 6 where it kind of
says the same thing that if if we reject
the knowledge yeah Hosea 4:6 my people
are destroyed for a lack of knowledge
because you have rejected knowledge I
will reject you from being priests for
me because you have forgotten the law of
your God I will also forget your
children talking about the Judgment that
comes upon Israel so it's not that
they're being punished because they
don't know it's because they're
rejecting truth they're re in light the
only alternative is the vacuum is then
filled with darkness and so God doesn't
send it it just comes consequentially
you might say God allows it because he
with draws truth like you say there's
only error left thank you James good
question next caller that we have is
Alan also listening California Ellen
you're on Bible answers live good
evening evening thank you for taking my
call I'm calling from Bakersfield
California my question is it's a the
first part of Daniel 9:26 says and after
62 weeks Messiah shall be cut off that's
the new King James version but not for
himself so that's pretty
self-explanatory Jesus died for our died
for us but then every other translation
says Messiah shall be cut off and have
nothing but how can those two things
mean the same thing well uh you're
talking about two translations and they
sound different by the way the King
James and the new King James are very
similar it says but not for himself um
Christ uh he did not he was not cut off
for his sin he was cut off for our sin
then and so I think that the King James
new King James which uh you know many
scholars accept I think it's more
accurate but either way with either
translation it's basically saying that
Christ is not cut off for his sin he's
cut off for ours and you know I think
there there are four ways in which that
phrase uh has been translated because of
the original language there it can go
it's very similar the one is the one
that you mentioned in the King James
where it says and uh but not for himself
but literally means and nothing to him
and some translate that is there will be
no help for him or no help with them
others translated as and he shall not be
meaning that He Shall Perish but not for
himself is also a meaning connected with
that phrase so depending upon which
translation you go with uh there's some
slight variations there but I think the
point is still clear when the Messiah is
cut off and even you know if the
messiah's cut up and it says and shall
have nothing they took everything from
him they did yeah so you can't argue
with that either but the point point
that I think is so incredible it says
that he'll cause the sacrifice to cease
and when Jesus was cut off the veil was
rent in the temple bringing to an end
the sacrificial system you know we have
a study guide called right on time that
deals with Daniel chapter n and gets
into the various time prophecies that
you have it's very interesting it's a
great study we'll be happy to send this
to anyone who calls and asks just call
800 835
6747 and you can ask for the study gu is
called right on time and we'll be happy
to send that to you as
6747 you can also just dial pound 250 on
your smartphone say Bible aners live and
then you'll be able to downloaded there
as well next caller that we have is uh
Joan in Australia Joan welcome to the
program hi thank you for taking my call
how are you doing good thank you for
calling I hope you can understand my
question it's kind of a little bit but
it's I'm just trying to get a picture of
um Job 1 verse6 when I understand um
when there was the sons of God my
question is are they the council or are
they the sons of God that write the
Books of life and is it just Old
Testament um and it doesn't happen
anymore where Satan had access to go
along with them there's a little bit of
mystery around the sons of God and who
they are I think there places the Bible
where it speaks of the angels as the
sons of God it's also talking here in
job I think it's talking about maybe the
you know this is Heavenly meeting but
it's not in heaven a Celestial meeting
where God is there and it says s Satan
comes from the earth so it's not on
Earth the sons of God there are um some
kind of Representatives of other worlds
now the reason we say that is because
one of the titles for Adam who was the
leader of this world he's called called
the Son of God you look in the genealogy
of of Jesus in The Book of Luke chapter
3 it says and Enos was the son of Seth
who was the son of Adam who was the son
of God Adam was not born he was created
to be the leader of this world now God
you know no doubt has intelligent beings
that are leaders of other worlds it
describes the 24 Elders around his
throne and Revelation some have wondered
is this who they are 1 John 3 says
behold what manner of love the father
has bestowed on us that we should be
called sons of God and Isaiah says that
we are Sons and Daughters of God
Believers Christ said that the wicked
they are sons of their father the devil
so the term sons of God it floats a
little bit in its definition in the
Bible I think in the immediate context
in job though it appears as though these
um sons of God would be the
representatives of other worlds Hebrews
speaks about God created the worlds and
he used his plural and it appears that
Satan came to this Gathering claiming to
be the representative of the earth and
it's interesting that that God allowed
him and God said where did you come from
he said oh from walking up and down on
the earth claiming that as his kingdom
and then God said well there's someone
in your kingdom that really belongs in
my kingdom and that's where the story of
job is you read on and tells you the
story of his experience so I I think we
can say that these sons of God would be
the representatives of of uh other
worlds and very possibly they could also
be the 24 Elders that you read about in
The Book of Revelation in and uh also I
believe in the Old Testament it refers
to God ruling before his Elders
gloriously yes which is the the same
idea you know we do have a book Pastor D
It's called who are the sons of God and
it deals with the subject and we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks the number is 800 835
6747 that is our free uh resource phone
line As for the book it's called who are
the sons of God we'll send it to you you
can also just dial pound 250 on your
smartphone ask for it and you'll be able
to download it that way as well amen
thank you Joan thanks for calling all
the way from Australia we've got Steve
in Missouri Steve welcome to the
program yeah Pastor Doug Pastor Ross um
I listen to your show pretty regular and
just just yesterday's my fact it was
recording but a man called in and said
when Jesus comes back how could ever I
seem if the Earth is round well a lot of
times we we're just not smart enough
to to figure out what God is capable of
doing first of all the Holy Spirit can
be everywhere it wants right we can't we
can't understand that okay but I'm I'm G
to say when Jesus comes back he's not
going to be over there in China and
China is going to call us and say hey
the Lord's here he's be he'll be there
in a little bit now I'm going to go
through about four verses and see what
you think okay all right let's let's
hear it all right I'm I'm going to start
start out with Revelation 6
verse4 and the heavens departed as a
scroll a scroll rolls
out okay rolls out like a scroll when it
is rolled together and every mountain
and Island were moved out of their
places now I'm going to jump over to
Revelation 16 verse 20 and every idland
fled away and the mountains were not
found so things are really happening now
I'm going to go to to Isaiah 40:4 for
every Valley shall be exalted and every
mountain and Hill shall be made low and
the Crooked shall be made straight and
the rough places
plain okay now I'm going to I'm going to
stay in Isaiah
1313 this where I'm going to go now okay
1313 therefore I will shake the heavens
and the Earth shall removed out of their
place and in the Wrath of the Lord's
host and in the day of his spirits anger
so that that's definitely a when he's
coming back is when that's going to
happen now I'm going to go to
Isaiah
2419 okay we got to wrap this up pretty
quick because we want to get to the
question okay this this this is the last
one
2419 the Earth is utterly broken down
the Earth is clean dissolved and the
Earth is moved exceedingly so it sounds
to me like this Earth's going to roll
out like a scroll where everybody could
seem at one time oh I see what you're
saying yeah well there's no question
that the uh the Earth is going to go
through tremendous turmoil but but I I
don't think you need to bend over
backwards to try to destroy the Earth
and make this verse fit when it says
every eye will see him it means on the
day of the Lord every eye will see him
every eye of everybody alive as Christ
goes around the world and it says we are
caught up to meet the Lord in the air it
says he's coming from the East I'm just
understanding the same way that the the
Earth rotates and he's going to sweep
around the circle of the earth everyone
will see him that day doesn't mean the
same moment as he comes the dead in
Christ will rise they're caught up to
meet him we're transformed we're caught
up to meet them and then he takes us
back to Glory he says I will take you to
the places The Mansions are prepared so
you know no question that the Earth is
going to be in great turmoil but I don't
know that the Earth is going to
disintegrate so that everybody sees him
at the same moment um anyway that'll be
I just want to be ready yeah however
that happens you know we do have a book
talking about the second coming of
Christ it's called anything but Secret
and it talks about these verses and some
of the events connected with the second
coming of Christ we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls and asks 8835
6747 ask for the book anything but
secret also you can dial pound 250 say
Bible answers live and ask for it by
name next caller that we have is Lee
listening in North Carolina Lee welcome
to Bible answers you are on the
air oh hi thank you for taking my call
my question please is the role of the
Holy spirit in heaven like I know that
Jesus comes back to get us and he brings
us to the father so I also have read
about the holy spirit being taken away
slowly from the earth maybe during the
tribulation I was just wondering when
it's all said and done and we're all in
heaven what's the role of the Holy
Spirit and how did he get there thank
you yeah good question well you know
Jesus said it's expedient that I go and
if I go I will send the comfort of the
Holy Spirit and he will be with you and
then Christ when he tells us I'm with
you wherever you go in Matthew chapter
28 well how is God With Us God is with
us through God the spirit uh Jesus said
you know he will uh take up my father
and and give it to you and so even in
heaven we will have God's spirit and
presence with us all through the cosmos
wherever we might roam through God the
spirit and so um communication with God
wherever we are is probably going to
transpire through the spirit because I
do believe that God has a place in time
that he sits enthroned there is a center
to his kingdom somewhere a capital says
he himself will dwell with us we will
see his face but as we go to Worlds
unknown and we travel or anywhere in the
world if we're building our mansions and
Country Homes God's still with us um
through his spirit so I think the the
work of the spirit's going to be still
very real it'll be different in that
it's not their convicting us of sin
because there's no sin then but we'll
still have the peace in the presence of
the
spirit all right next qu that we have is
Taiwan listening from Alabama well hey
pastors I just wanted to ask in Hebrews
4:5 and again in this place they shall
not enter my wrist I wanted to see if
that's the Sabbath he was referring
to um no in in a word uh in Hebrews he's
talking about um you know the rest that
we have through salvation in Christ the
children of Israel looked upon the
promis land as the rest instead of
wandering and even as they first entered
they had to fight the Canaanites finally
when they were all subdued they could go
to their homes and plant their Vineyards
and they called that entering their rest
so it's compared to the Sabbath in
Hebrews 4 but um uh it's Hebrews here
the writer we believe is Paul he's
talking about Joshua in the Old
Testament uh bringing them into rest how
David was speaking in the Psalms of the
rest that we have in the Lord and the
Sabbath is a symbol of that rest but
he's really talking about
Jesus said uh when he says I swore in my
wrath they will not enter my rest the
people that didn't believe in the
wilderness did not make it to the
promised land they lost faith and again
then he quotes they shall not enter my
rest again he's quoting from uh verse
three in the same passage so hope that
makes a little sense but uh he uses the
Sabbath here in sort of a symbolic sense
he does say there remains therefore a
Sabbath for the people of God and I
think that's talking about of course
there is a Sabbath day but there's also
a Sabbath rest that we have in Christ
all right thank you next caller that we
have is Lee listening in Texas Lee
welcome to the program yes thank you for
taking my call tonight I have a question
that been uh on my mind for many many
years
now and hopefully I can finally get some
finally get the answer to it okay my
question is Jesus always said that he
and the father are one so everything
that God knows that he he would know
know as well but if that's the case why
did Jesus say that he didn't know the
date and time of his return when he's
supposed to know I mean he knows
everything that God knows did he lie
about that or he just could say anything
about it no I think that
when Christ spoke of his second coming
he made that statement that the Angels
don't know but the father only Christ on
Earth had divested himself a lot of a
lot of his Supernatural knowledge and
when Jesus was on Earth he did not know
and think about it for a moment if he
did know a date how would he tell the
disciples that he was coming in you know
2050 I'm just making that up they didn't
even keep time like that it would have
made no sense to them they they didn't
understand that calendar we use today so
I think Christ said look you know here
now on Earth I don't know but you can be
certain that Christ now glorified at the
right hand of the Father God the father
is not holding an envelope like people
at some award ceremony and saying I
can't tell you when you're supposed to
come back it's a secret no Jesus is
omniscent he knows everything now but
when he was a human on earth he laid
aside a lot of his divinity so yes I'm
quite sure Jesus knows now hey you know
Pastor Ross we're going to take a break
and don't go anywhere more questions
coming in just a
[Music]
moment stay tuned Bible answers live
will return
[Music]
shortly amazing facts change lives
my life was in
turmoil my wife and I were fighting all
the time I got away from everything and
everybody I don't know it just I always
had this emptiness in my heart I don't
want it filled I just felt like I went
my whole life you know just searching
for something and my father died and
that ruined me a lot my father didn't
believe in
suicide I didn't want to live but rather
than disrespect him I decided I would
just become so mean that someone else
would do it to me and I wouldn't have to
to so I joined the army thinking what
better place to get killed than in the
Army now while I was in the Army my
daughter got injured she uh was in an
accident and she was blind and
paraplegic and it's just like I felt the
whole world was coming down all in one
morning I just really got mad and I gave
God a cussing like you wouldn't believe
I said I'm not Moses not Abraham you
know I don't but I put my sandals on
just like they do and I'm a man I don't
want to know why this is happening to me
I just want to know that it's happening
for a reason if you tell me right now
this is all for a reason then you can
stack it on me from here to the end of
time and I will never complain again and
that little TV came on had had been
sitting there just static all night long
and there's this Minister when he pops
up and it says today's lesson is from
The Book of Job God only lets those
suffer that he loves the most and I said
well that's all you had to say Lord I
appreciate him from that day forward I
knew that he was there and he was in my
life and that he would help me I went to
prison just almost immediately after
that I was in prison for aggravated
assault I was in one of the worst
prisons in state of Tennessee it was
full of gang activity I got my throat
cut 52
stitches my neck I could take those
fingers and stick them all the way
through out my mouth I'd gone to the
library that day because it it was
really about the only thing to do but I
ran across this little book called the
richest cavan this book is hilarious but
it is great I'm sitting there with this
big beard and I'm thinking hey I know
what it's like look like a cavan but I'm
not an educated person I guess you'd say
but I'm a simple guy I'm just really a
simple guy and that's what I loved about
Doug Bachelor because this guy is just
straight out as you can get and my wife
and I we've kept kept contact through
all these
years
and so much has gone on and I told her I
said listen now this is the center of my
world right now and I said I really want
you to be involved in it with me I need
it and I said you will too if you ever
just take hold of it I told my wife I
said listen they've got this amazing
facts Bible study going here and this is
the best way for you to get this
information and I think because it's
broken down and they give you
questions and to to make you look for
these things you know so it's not anyone
telling you you find it on your own and
they teach you to actually use the Bible
she was there Faithfully every
Wednesday until we decided you know she
wanted to be baptized also she saw it
coming around uh the choice was made in
October 4th 24 14 my wife and I we were
baptized in the water at the same time
and we started our walk together I guess
you'd say I went through everything that
a man could possibly go through I
guess from marital trouble loss of
family members death in my family my
children were harmed and my daughter's
handicapped for life I went to prison
but still I kept my word to God that he
could stack it on me as much as he
wanted and I'd never question him again
and I
didn't but I can say this much he never
put nothing on me that I couldn't handle
and he walked with me through it all and
I'd like to say that to anyone who is in
prison not to give up don't lose hope
put your faith in the Lord and study and
seek Him and He will seek you and I my
name is Charlie green and I want you to
know that you and amazing facts have
changed my
[Music]
life you're listening to Bible answers
live where every question answered
provides a clearer picture of God and
his plan to save you so what are you
waiting for get practical answers about
the good book for a better life
today this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answer
answers to your Bible related questions
on the air please call us next Sunday
between 7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 800
83567 47 once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends to
Bible answers live and if you've joined
us in route this is a live International
interactive Bible study and you can
participate by listening or calling in
with your Bible questions think we still
have some lines open the number is 800
God says that's 800 463
7297 I am Doug Bachelor my name is Jean
Ross and we have Nell listening in
California n welcome to the program H
thank you um Pastor Johan and Pastor
Doug um my question has to do with Ain
my um question is is why didn't God
forgive Ain because um I believe it was
Joshua when he asked him he said you
know confess now what thou Hast done and
give God the praise and Ain seemed to
have confessed immediately um so I was
wondering why he and his family were
still
killed well achen did not confess until
they cast lots he waited to the last
moment and basically the lot fell on him
so you know God basically you know he
got caught with the chocolate chips
around his mouth and and then he said
yeah yeah I'm guilty so his repentance
wasn't really heartfelt his repentance
was after God sort of fingered him and
said you're the one um and the reason
his family probably was judged with him
is they were
accomplice um they all knew it was
hidden in the tent they were you know is
probably dug a hole under the rug or I
don't know how he did it but they all
knew about the stolen booty and they
helped him keep it a secret and it also
reminds us that uh our decisions can
affect our families for their salvation
as in the story of Noah or their
destruction as in the story of aen and
so um yeah I think that they were
probably complicit with what was
happening we don't know that there were
any little children in his family they
may have been older kids that were of
age all right next caller that we have
is Dan in North Carolina Dan welcome to
Bible answers live yes good evening
pastors thank you so much Pastor I got a
a question that uh I don't know if it's
been an approach before maybe yes maybe
no but my wife and I are of uh radically
different religious
beliefs and I my basic question is uh
how would one defined unequally yolked
uh in the case of separating yeah well
uh did one of you change faiths after
you got
married no we were uh uh that is my
mistake actually um I was who and what I
was and she was uh struggling she really
didn't know where she wanted to be um
and and I have tried progressively to um
not aggressively but progressively to
introduce her to uh my thought it's my
beliefs uh that which I hold true and
it's uh don't feel like you're making
progress becomes yeah she becomes
offensive now it's to the point where I
can't bring up anything uh it turns into
drama and well I don't I don't want that
that's I want to make sure we keep it
you know this is of course a Bible
question program it'd be easy to
transition into counseling let let me
tell you what the Bible says um the
Bible says that in the event that you've
got a believer that is married to an
unbeliever if the unbeliever let's
assume that your wife is is not
believing the truth it may be you that
isn't believing the truth so I don't
know don't know what your different
faiths are but if they're willing to
dwell together they should not divorce
and that's 1 Corinthians chapter 7 so I
recommend you read the whole chapter
there because he talks about when people
of opposing faiths are find themselves
married um and especially if there's
children involved um you know you want
to create as much Harmony and peace as
you can even though no question there
it's going to be difficult now that's a
different story though if you're dating
someone and you're thinking about
marrying them and you dating a person or
you engage to a person that is of a
different Faith well you know you
probably won't you don't want to proceed
with that marriage until there is a
Unity of belief otherwise it's just
going to cause problems yeah yeah but uh
he's telling us that that's what
happened now they're
married once you've said I do you made
the Covenant you kind of went in Eyes
Wide Open someone said before marriage
go in with your eyes wide open and after
marriage keep them half shut to The
Faults of to your spouse you know we do
have a book Pastor that you wrote It's
called uh marriage divorce and
remarriage and you address these these
issues the number to call for that is
8835 6747 once again it's free we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks what is the Bible say about the
subject of marriage and remarriage 800
6747 you can dial pound 250 on your
smartphone you'll be able to read a
digital copy of that lesson or that book
next holiday we have is Glenn in Ohio
Glenn welcome to Bible answers live
thank you very much pastors for taking
my call my Call is even concerns the
trunity of the godhead and the Holy
Spirit you know there's an interesting
subject I believe about why Jesus told
the apostles he had to go so that he
could send the Holy Spirit I think
that'd be an interesting subject we love
to hear talked about but the trunity of
the godhead Elohim came to Christianity
from myth's son
worship my thought about it is I believe
that there's God the Father God the Son
and the Holy Spirit as the omnipresence
of the godhead
in other words there were millions of
people that were not neglected when the
Holy Spirit manifest himself as the
death of Jesus baptism so I I believe
there's the Father the Son and the
manifestation of the the omnipresence of
the godhead I never heard never hear
that word can you help me or how's how
does that thought fit yeah so I I think
what you're asking is is the holy spirit
a unique separate person or is he just
uh the way that the omnipresence of God
the father and son has demonstrated well
when in Acts chap 5 when ananas and saf
lied uh regarding their Their donation
that they made Peter said you've not
lied unto men but when you lied to the
Holy Spirit you lied to God and so Peter
defines lying to the Holy Spirit as
lying to God so when you look at the
definitions of God you find that the
Holy Spirit uh also fulfills the
definitions
that he is grieved he's given an
individual
personality um that's part of the reason
Jesus said go baptize in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit so
you've got it's distinct you find the
Holy Spirit at the beginning the spirit
of God moved upon the face of the waters
and you have the spirit giving an
invitation in the end of the Bible where
it says the spirit and the bride say
come so the holy spirit is a separate
person and you know this is it's a
difficult subject and I won't pretend it
isn't and we need to really take our
shoes off when we talk about this
because um when man starts describing
and defining God we're way out of our
league but based on what is revealed I
think we can say with confidence you've
got three distinct persons in the
godhead and I have a book on that that
uh it's called the Holy Spirit Trinity
one God or three and you'll be blessed
by that Glenn please look at it 8835
6747 ask for the book called The Trinity
one God or3 we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks again it's 800
83567 47 you can also dial pound 250 on
your smartphone say Bible aners live ask
for the book uh by name and you'll be
able to get a digital download and read
that right there on your phone next
caller that we have uh thank you Glenn
next caller we have is Brett Brent in
Georgia Brent welcome to the program
good evening pastors how are you all
doing good thank you so I'm I'm
interested in Proverbs 23 vers uh 20 and
21 and really looking at that and it
talks about overindulgence and and
gluttonous and so I guess looking at
that will there be obese people in
heaven I'm
sorry well I shouldn't laugh I I think
I'm just thinking will we have obese
bodies in heaven no I don't think so uh
is it possible for obese person to be
saved is that maybe what you're asking I
I know that's possible I
guess asking I I know that's possible I
guess yeah I don't think in the
resurrection anybody's you see obesity
is technically it's it's an unhealthy
condition and so I don't think anyone's
going to get a glorified body that's
unhealthy does that make sense I don't
know if we've ever had that question
yeah I mean there's different factors
for for obesity I mean one could just be
in Temperance but they could also be
Medical reasons there's other factors
that come into play so yeah there are
health risks of course as we know it can
shorten a person's life if if they're
obese but that's not preventing someone
from receiving Christ and being saved
but like you say Pastor D I think
everyone is going to have that perfect
body when Jesus comes yeah and I don't
know too many obese people that uh think
it is a good thing for them to be
struggling with weight so they're
looking forward to that brand new body
as well believer now let's suppose you
have a person that's uh you know 100 PB
overweight which would be unhealthy um
and they find the Lord and they come to
the Lord and they start you know working
to make changes in their lifestyle and
they die before they get there um well
you know it's a process and and so
they'd certainly be saved um but then
there's the other question is gluttony a
sin and I think we need to say the lusts
of the flesh whether it's sexual a drug
addiction or gluttony those are all sins
that should be overcome MH all right
good question first time we've had that
one next caller that we have uh let's
see calling from New Jersey and it's
spani spani welcome to the program thank
you pastors for taking my call how are
you doing great thanks for
calling no problem so my question today
is about Genesis chapter 22 what if God
refers to Isaac as Abraham's only son
son when obviously he had Ismael first
yeah good question uh I I think it's
because um having Ishmael was not God's
plan um God's plan was that through his
son Abraham's son with Sarah the Messiah
would come when Abraham and Sarah became
impatient because they thought oh well
you know Sarah's getting too old she's
beyond the age of bearing we're going to
help God out we're going to get this
Egyptian slave and use her as a
surrogate and and then you know Abraham
and Hagar have the son Ishmael
ultimately Hagar and Ishmael are sent
away and it's kind of hard for us to to
understand this but God basically said
put her away and the word is
divorce so the the son that God was
going to bring the Messiah through was
Isaac now Abraham married after Sarah
died and he threw a woman named coutura
and he had several other Sons
but when he offered his only son Isaac
was a type of Christ and God so loved
the world he gave his son God doesn't
have several Divine Sons he only had
Jesus Isaac was a type of that and I
think Isaac's the only one of Abraham's
children that was a miracle birth
through Sarah that's yeah good point
whereas the all the others was sort of
and I think as you said that's a type of
Christ Jesus of course there was a
miracle birth with Mary uh and it also
is a reference to that it's God that
would fulfill the promise it would it
was a man that was to fulfill the
promise so in that sense Isaac is
different from the other sons that Abra
had I think Paul addresses that too one
was a a child of kind of works and one
was a child of Faith MH yeah so hope
that helps a little bit and good
question thank you Richard in Arkansas
is listening Richard welcome to the
program hey thank you for having me how
are youall doing tonight great thanks
for
calling I just have one quick question
I'll make it short for yall what does
the Bible say about our pets being in
heaven yeah that that is a good question
we've had that from time to time because
um a lot of folks like myself Pastor
Ross has probably had beloved pets and
and uh you know usually humans outlive
them unless you get a turtle a tortoise
or something um you had a parrot for a
long time we did they long long time I'm
laughing at their P some of these
turtles or or tortoises can live like
two 300 years they can out you and your
children yeah they can go they don't
have a lot of Personality though but uh
anyway um and so you know we wonder is
there any hope for them we we love some
of these pets and and we'd love to see
them again are they gone forever uh you
know the Bible I have to tell you the
Bible does not specifically address it
what the Bible does say is there will be
animals in heaven so we know that and
then the Bible says that uh the eyes
have not seen the ear has not heard
neither has entered Into the Heart
meaning the imagination of man what God
has prepared for those that love him so
I think when we get to heaven there'll
be a lot of amazing surprises and among
those
surprises that are uh Joyful We may find
that God is resurrecting our beloved cat
or dog or parakeet or whatever it was
and that they're going to be there with
a glorified body we don't know that but
uh certainly not Beyond him that's as
close as I think we can come now we've
got a friend Steve Walberg he wrote a
book I will my pit be in heaven and I
think he he ends up with the argument
that yes if it was a good pet now dogs
maybe not cats but dogs will be in it
I'm G to get all these letters cat
owners now all right well thank you
Richard next qu that we have is
Elizabeth in Colorado Elizabeth welcome
to the
program thank you hi thanks for
calling hi um my question is well Jesus
forgive Pontius poot because in the
Bible it says when he first went to
Pontius po when they sent him over there
that pontious pul finding wrong in him
yeah well you know in the dialogue
between Jesus and pilate Jesus does say
the one who turned me over to you has
the greater sin he didn't say pilot was
sinless uh pilate said Jesus was
innocent and in spite of the fact he was
innocent he saidwell to make you happy
I'll beat him and then let him go'
and well if you think he's innocent why
are you going to beat him and then
because the mob is crying for his blood
instead of calling out the garden saying
he's innocent I'm going to protect him
he hands him over because he's worried
about his career and how it's going to
look to the Romans if there's a riot um
so I I think pilate caved and I I
believe he's going to be lost now I
think you know Christ is merciful in the
Judgment he realized pilot was pressured
into it and God takes that into account
but I don't think Pilot's going to make
it based on what the Bible record is and
it's not in the scripture but in
Christian history and Roman history it
seems to say he was eventually banished
to Spain I believe it was Spain and he
committed
suicide so um he his wife warned him in
a dream don't have anything to do with
that just man and pilate knew he was
just and he still condemned him so I
think he's guilty and that almost makes
it worse he knew that Christ was
innocent and yet he's still condemned to
death he murdered him yeah so all right
thank you Elizabeth we've got Joe in New
Mexico Joe welcome to the
program good evening pastors how are you
good thank you Joe appreciate your
calling and thank you for accepted by
call I was wondering where was Daniel
when hananiah AR and ananas and those
guys were in the at the golden temple
the golden statue where was Daniel yeah
that's a that's a good question it's a
little mysterious uh my idea Pastor Ross
just got done teaching a series on
Daniel my understanding is that um
Nebuchadnezzar knowing that Daniel had
told him his golden Kingdom would not
continue might have sent him off on
business in another part of the Kingdom
uh I I don't think it was an accident
Daniel was not there but um you got any
thoughts yeah it's almost as if
Nebuchadnezzar had forgotten about
Shadrach mhach and abedo or Han and I
Michelle and Azariah which are the
Hebrew names because when they came
before the king he gave them a second
chance which you'd think you wouldn't
have done to anyone else yeah but it's
as if he suddenly realizes oh man I
forgot about these guys and they good
you know they're good loyal so he said
well we'll give you another chance when
you hear the music bow down of course
when they said oh King don't you know
you don't have to give us another chance
we worship the God we're not going to
bow down well then he got Furious and
then you know the furnace was heated
seven times hotter so it almost appears
as though yes he remember Daniel or
maybe sent him off some errand but he
forgot about his three friends yeah and
yet they were just as faithful as Daniel
what a story I mean can you imagine if
we didn't have that great story uh
Daniel chapter 3 so yeah they were very
loyal just like just like Daniel yeah I
heard one Bible scholar say that the
Lord accomplished through those three
young men on the plains of dura that day
what he had been wanting to do through
the Jewish Nation for a thousand years
to be a light to the Gentiles and they
stood up and show the power of Jehovah
and then of course the king sends out a
declaration to the whole empire about
the God of Daniel and Han and I Michel
and Azariah anyway thanks of course
Daniel had his time too in the next
Kingdom in the daras where he was
putting the Lion's dance so he stood up
he had to stand up to all right next
caller that we have is Eric in Michigan
Eric welcome to the
program hey how you guys doing tonight
good thank you for
calling um I'm looking for clarification
of my thought process uh due to my
limited understanding I've been running
parallels with the operating system of
the
sanctuary uh um comparing it to the
disciples and how they were taught um
through Jesus and I noticed when you
come into the courtyard of of the uh
Sanctuary the first thing you come to is
the altar which is where would be where
Jesus or you know would be sacrificed in
the New Testament so he'd be starting at
the cross in the New Testament but the
next thing you come to in the courtyard
I believe is the labor where you have
water
baptism and then after the water baptism
you go into the holy place where you
have the 12 loaves of sh bread which
would be the 12 tribes of Israel you're
learning you know you're learn there's a
learning process going on there um where
you'd eventually be Sanctified well of
course the Old Testament I understand
that you know men chose not to obey so
then you go into the New Testament and
then um if you're starting at the cross
when Jesus was resurrected I believe he
was taught for I think 40 days and then
after that 40 days the disciples got got
the water baptism and then after the
water baptism you have the
um oh Pentecost where the Holy Spirit
came down on top of them I guess is the
center line is like the center of the
Bible and if you go into the past or
into the future you're in a teaching
situ situation if you go farther into
the past or the future you have the
water baptism it's almost like it it's
laid out and then of course you have if
you go even farther into the past or
into the future you end up with being
you're Sanctified because you would be
in the Holy Place being Sanctified or in
the future let me jump in and tell you
what I do think and you may be
overthinking it is that okay perfect um
I do think the sanctuary outlines the
process of Salvation and I was with you
when you said
you know first thing there's one door
Christ is the door first thing you
encounter then is sacrifice the altar
it's the cross the children of Israel
and you see the sanctuary is tracing
their Journey to the promised land the
children of Israel they sacrificed the
lamb then they went through the Red Sea
that's baptism in the wilderness then
they had bread and that's the 12 loaves
12 tribes 12 Apostles it's talking about
God's word and Jesus is the bread you've
got the light they had a pillar of fire
in the sanctuary God guided them and
that it's a symbol for you know the
spirit then you have the altar of
incense this is prayer so you have the
the three disciplines of the Christian
Life are in the sanctuary the bread we
read our Bibles the light we let our
light shine and the prayer we communion
with God so in the wilderness you've got
those three principal disciplines of the
Christian Life there's a lot more to it
but I'm just simplifying it
and then the whole idea is you go to the
third phase which is glorification in
the presence of God and having him dwell
in our minds Thy word I have hid in my
heart so you got justification in the
courtyard sanctification in the Holy
place glorification in the most holy
place so just think of it in simple
terms uh I'm I know that I've heard some
studies on the sanctuary that they can
write a whole encyclopedia on it it's a
deep deep subject but probably more than
we can accomplish in little sound bites
of our answered time so didn't mean to
catch you off but uh you were getting
pretty deep there you know we do have a
study guide talking about that it's
called God drew the pl our new magazine
and we have a magazine talking about the
sanctury too and as you said uh Pastor
Doug there's there's many different
facets and parts to the sanctuary and
its application so call and ask for that
uh the number is 800 835
6747 you can ask for the study guide
It's called God drew the plans it's on
the sanctuary the amazing facts magazine
he's also entitled what is that amazing
Sanctuary I think that's just what it is
amazing Sanctuary so you can ask for
that as well I think Eric would like
that because it it gets a little deeper
into the the symbolism Sanctuary the
time prophecies connected with it all
right do we have time for one more
Rebecca in Pennsylvania Rebecca we got
about a minute okay real quick so uh my
question was about the Lord's Prayer one
line says um lead us not into temptation
so um someone said it was anti-christian
to say the Lord's Prayer because of that
line because God does not lead us into
temptation Satan does so what do you
think about how do you interpret that
line you know what it's actually not the
best translation it's basically saying
lead us away from our natural tendency
towards Temptation so he we're saying
lead us not meaning lead us away from
Temptation we're going to Bid Farewell
God bless you to those listening on
satellite radio we'll be back next week
to stud with you for those who are
listening on landbased Stations don't go
anywhere this is when we come back and
do our rapid fire internet questions
that have come
in Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible
questions did you know amazing facts has
a free Bible school that you can do from
the comfort of your own home it includes
27 beautifully Illustrated study lessons
to Aid in your study of God's word sign
up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 1844
2157 that's 1844
257000 thank you for listening to
today's broadcast we hope you understand
your Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
yeah welcome back friends to our um
email questions and if you have a Bible
related question you'd like to email us
it's just B questions
amazingfacts.org all right Pastor I here
we go some great questions tonight
Cynthia is asking what were the laws
before the Ten Commandments were given
after all isn't sin the transgression of
the law yeah some folks say that well
before the law was given where there's
no law there's no sin then you know how
did they know right from wrong the 10
Commandments were written down in the
time of Moses there in Exodus chapter 20
but they existed they've always existed
it is always been wrong to worship other
gods it's always been wrong to take
innocent life and how do we know that
well when God says to Cain sin lies at
your door and Cain commits murder he
knew murder was a sin when Joseph says
now Joseph lived long before Moses when
he was tempted by Piper's wife and
Joseph said how can I this sin of
adultery and sin against my master
Joseph knew that adultery was a sin and
so you could go through a Litany of sins
that they understood it was lawlessness
before the Ten Commandments were given
the law was still there it just wasn't
cified yet okay we've got Alex who's
asking does the bible say that Adam and
Eve ate of the tree of life before they
sinned and if so why didn't they become
immortal yeah we would assume they did
eat from the Tree of Life and evidently
it's something you do more than once in
eternity because God says that the tree
of life is in the new Earth and that
there's different kinds of fruit
intimating that we would come you know
different varieties or different uh
flavors I'm not sure but it says there's
12 different kinds it sounds like 12
times a year so um you know we'll come
different times we'll eat the fruit and
it must perpetuate life for a long time
because Adam ate from the fruit he lived
900 years whereas you know today we have
three score and 10 as an average so we
think he did eat but evidently it's
something that you do
ongoing uh I don't think our eternal
life is so much coming from the fruit
like if you get too far out in the
cosmos and you miss your meal you're
going to die I think we have eternal
life but we're going to want to keep
eating from the tree all right last
question we have here is uh what would
have happened if Judas scariot repented
of his sin after all the Bible predicted
that he was to betray Christ
yeah well of course if he had genuinely
repented I think he would have been
forgiven but he reached the point of no
return when he um he betrayed Christ it
says Satan entered him he went out and
it was dark don't let that happen to you
friends listen to the voice of the
spirit we'll study God's word with you
again next week God
[Music]
bless this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
700 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast call us at 800
83567 47 or visit our website at
amazingfacts.org tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions